I'm not trying to over dramatize this
but that was that was alarming
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even had her wings and
today we close out season six with Jeff
Goldblum you known from iconic roles and
films like the fly drastic Park
Independence Day and many more you can
catch him in the mountain which is
headed to the Venice Film Festival and
if all that weren't enough he's
releasing his debut jazz album this fall
with his band the mildred schnitzer
orchestra jeff goldblum welcome to the
show thank you very very much it's a
pleasure to be here
how are you at spicy food I in my life
I'm an event an adventurous eater I mean
there's nothing I haven't tried after I
moved around Pittsburgh I went mmm
Thai what's this Indian what's that I
like it now I like to be careful but
with one thing or another vocal chords I
think of them anyway I'm not gonna bore
you with it
so I'm supposed to not have spicy food
food these days as per my voice doctor
but I have a strategy which is that
where you get there I'm gonna nibble
maybe that's a is that a good is that is
that cheating it's a worn path and
here's the deal there's no rules here
it's not the Olympics that people seem
to respect the people who commit a
little bit more to the wings but you
know what what do you have to prove yeah
I don't think stoicism or
Competitiveness that's not part of my I
don't have it I can take it I can take
it or I don't need you know and
Competitiveness if I'm on that wall of
shame it's obvious I know and I you know
with that little sequence that you play
and add people it's sad it's shameful
and that music is you know want to be
part of that but what do I care
well we have formidable opponents in
front of us the hottest vegan chicken
wings in the history of the world ready
to do it one last time for season six
Jeff Goldblum yes I am I like all your
all your gestures
[Music]
it's still fried but what is it - a
tempeh or tofu or something like that
it's tempeh tempeh tempeh tempeh wings
okay alright your beginning oh wow
it's the howler monkey ah come on this
is supposed to be the baby level okay
you know sure so I tasted it on my
tongue already so apropos of nothing my
dad is very excited for today's
interview and for the first time in six
seasons he has a request he wants me to
ask you about one of his favorite shows
that he says never got a chance to shine
I have an idea let me guess sweet brown
shoe it is ten-speed and brown shoe I
know it how did you know that I'm
thinking your age your dad and you know
Bill Clinton not to name drop names but
either one of the times I met him one a
couple of times I met him he was like
Jeff I'd like a lot of your word
impersonation I like a lot of your work
I never missed an episode of ten-speed
and brown shoe that's recent why do you
think guys like Bill Clinton and my dad
like ten-speed brown shoe it was a
well-liked show we did 13 episodes
Steven J Connell did it do you know what
other shows he did in your trivial he
was the mastermind behind the Rockford
Files James Garner he also did greatest
American hero with William Katt who can
sing the theme song to that I'm looking
around the room I don't have hi no one
really believe it or not I'm walking on
air okay so good that was it
you better warn me this time now it's
heartbeat hot sauce yep got nice teeth
to look at
I actually don't I think once I get a
bag I'm fixing these get a bag you know
what it's not what the kids say what
yeah yeah big payday yeah I'll get a bag
I never heard that there you go
really what's wrong with the chump I
don't know I've always been kind of
self-conscious about it I think I see
those that's what you know I see that
mm-hmm I think they're fine and dandy
I appreciate that Jeff anyway hey true
or false
I've never had a cavity or filling I'm
gonna say that that's true absolutely
true now there might be some chicken
some tempeh in it but don't mistake that
for a cavity that's amazing there are
medical marvel okay don't go to if I'm
okay already okay you already did it I
already know your your left
unnhhh uhhh unbothered I Jeff Goldblum
you're a man of many mysteries not the
least with food you seem to be equal
parts gourmand and health nut
adventurous at heart but you also have
these idiosyncratic dietary preferences
what do you think is Pittsburgh's
greatest contribution to America's
culinary canon yeah I like the way you
talk I'm from Pittsburgh of course and I
was never part of the blue-collar
you know food culture there but you know
Isley's for this is gonna be only entry
of interest to people of Maeby's a
nostalgic regional sensibilities but
there used to be a place Isley's when i
was growing up that was fantastic
fantastic and they had ice cream cones
was a cone didn't get it I don't think
you could get it in a cup was a cone but
it was fashioned in some kind of high
mountain a little skinny mountain oh
it's great on all different flavor is
fantastic so Isley's i think was a but
then Isley's also had chipped ham have
you ever heard of such a thing ever had
chipped ham it was yeah I haven't heard
it referred to or seen it around
anywhere besides Pittsburgh then I don't
know if they have it now chipped ham was
great I don't know what kind of hammer
was but they put it on a slicer you'd
see right in frenzy when you bought it
and they put in a piece of paper you
know I'll have a half a pound of chipped
ham and you're very thin sliced I guess
it was ham and chipped I guess that was
the thinness of the slices and we take
it home and make sandwiches out of it
and then we called it sloppy joes but I
know you know and everyone knows sloppy
joes are ground meat with tomatoey sauce
but we called barbecue sauce maybe even
they sold barbecue sauce that you meant
to put on it and heat it up Hot Chip ham
with barbecue sauce
[Music]
that's mustardy I like all kind of
mustard I love mustard okay quit gawking
at me man says we touched down in your
intro you play in a jazz band and
regularly perform at Rockwell's I'm
Louis viewless jazz has a language
that's all its own so what I want to do
is throw some jazz club slang at you and
if you know the word maybe you can
explain it to the audience out there and
use it in a sentence does that sound
good I love the game I love any kind of
game let's go noodling noodling yes what
do I use it first in the sentence or
explain it explain it by way of using in
a sentence there's no rule to see more
fluid noodley I'm just gonna sit here
I'm just one of my plan I don't know I'm
just noodling around I'm just noodling
I'm just doing some noodling which means
with no particular purpose not in no
particular intensity you know what our
clams well we know what we know what's
clams little clams are but in the jazz
if it's used in [ __ ] I think I think
it's a wrong note I think it's a bad no
of course some say in jazz there's no
mistake if you incorporate it you know
cleverly but I think a clam is like a a
bad note I'm not sure of that is that it
Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing and finally can
you teach me how to scat cuz all I know
is that Skippy to be pop but a boat I
just know that one you've done it that's
it but are you perfuse that's something
you've repeated before scat make it up
now you know that again but about a B
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
but you're very good you can't once once
you get started sorry to stop so that
skit little bubbles is very good you
know anything scat is any anything that
you that you make up that's improv a
Satori that's a lyric list you know it's
like that I learned to listen to this I
learned you know Danny Kaye you remember
Danny Kaye really really does anybody
know Danny Kaye
a Oh for heaven's sakes anyway Danny
Kaye was a movie actor and musician but
he had a scat bit that I memorized
it's went like this and I still do it to
this day and my kids see more like me
woody maybe the people-to-people debate
and I thought that it's about today I'm
a favor hey hey there look up games look
through gay even the beep up hey hey hey
little a bit about the pain from bein
from bein from it even to give you
builds babe eat Giada Leahy Giada lay
even to give me vittles battles about
the Journal of a bat that that's it son
of zombie oh it's quite delicious
Suns on the wing sauce so you've been in
some of the biggest films ever made but
you also have achieved this ubiquitous
internet fame what's the difference
between a fan who sees you on the street
and recognizes you from the latest Wes
Anderson movie versus somebody who
approaches you because they want a
selfie with the Goldblum wow I love that
whole question there are many types but
you know oftentimes as you suggest I
think in the question they can be less
you know knowledgeable about you know
cinema you know hey it's the gold book
or or you get people who say somebody
yesterday said to me you know are you
still doing that acting thing you get
that - and I look at hashtag Jeff go
through on my Instagram alright I'll see
if they posted what amuses you or
disturbs you when you read your own
Instagram comments they don't seem to
get unpleasant from what I gather how
about when people call you daddy
does that make you feel good oh sweet
isn't that sexy talk
yeah a nice sexy talk yeah and I am a
daddy literally so even if they mean hey
daddy or daddy I am daddy and if they
means addy sometimes they say daddy
yeah what's that mean I think that
that's a little bit really more ha this
is more more on this side I'm on this
side of the daddy spicy daddy
yeah I'll I sure I like it Satya
while scallion tests I believe that's
Spanish this is my favorite part the
silence that falls upon the room as
we're done my favorite part my favorite
part of making a movie is when they go I
don't know if they do it anymore
we got to get room tone the sound guys
were nobody we gotta get room tone
everybody stops where they are they
can't move everybody that's been warring
different hats and done different jobs
they'll stop a guy I love these guys the
guy this guy does that and for about 30
seconds or sometimes they everybody saw
and there's total silence alright Jeff
we've recruited segments on our show
called explain that Graham where you do
a deep dive and I guess Instagram
interesting pictures that need more
context I'll bust out the laptop I'll
show you the picture then you just tell
me the beer story does that sound good
bass bass laptop please really you're a
fast talker are you keeping up yes yes
no anyway what am i picking this up for
it's a bit too soon what do you remember
about hanging out with quavo did he get
you into gucci belts I love that Cueva
this is in San Laurel the store where I
yes where I got these pink pants these
soft pink pants and these boots which we
call the Jodhpur boots with the hi not
that I need any more height but with the
highest heel I got those in that very
store and one day I saw him there also
shopping he was very sweet he's well you
know I'm an artist also and I really
like your bison oh my gosh I sit at your
feet
there's just hello at all and of all and
you know we just breathed in each
other's essence I absorbed it and made
it part of my own and I'll never forget
it
do you have any opinion of this 25 foot
bare-chested statue and potter's field I
love it
it's what is it 330 pounds I think they
said and it's 25 feet tall and fantastic
and was done for the to commemorate the
25th anniversary of the original
Jurassic Park movie I've seen many
renditions of renderings of me in that
scene and that's a final I'm sure this
particular pose it's immortal you know
it's all over the Internet you get a
kick out of that
I do yeah I wouldn't call out or if it's
immortal immortal means never never die
well time will tell I guess right Jeff
well time is fleeting as we know even in
the largest you had Neil deGrasse Tyson
here I saw I did he will tell you call
him up oh yes it's all our little lives
and that little thing our cosmic
calendar wise it's just a snap snippety
snap and then you know and the whole
thing is gonna go out at some point too
which makes it such a miracle that you
and I found each other to sit at this
table and eat wings on YouTube I agree
entirely miracle in the scientific sense
in the cosmic and the real factual sense
yes we don't have to look anywhere else
in you know nincompoop er II besides the
facts of the real universe to be
astounded with the miraculous what the
heck is this black garlic and Carolina
Reaper
fine and dandy him him this is a change
in demeanor a little bit helpers yep can
sober up and stuff goodbye and it's
laughter that I want to you know so my
guess is there isn't an interview that
goes by where you don't get asked about
Jurassic Park it has such a large
imprint on pop culture there are dozens
of articles that talk about the lore
surrounding Jurassic Park so what I want
to do is give you some of the widespread
mythology and you can tell me if it was
fact or fiction I read that the
animatronic t-rex would sometimes
malfunction and turn on on its own
frightening everybody on set is that
true yeah that's true they said be
careful everybody they gave us a safety
talk there know if it scared everybody
but the safety talk it scared me enough
to be serious about it they said don't
go near it because you know it's all
computers and buttons and then and it
may have a mind of its own and and you
don't want to and that's a really heavy
thing it's actually heavy and you don't
want it to fall falling speaking of the
t-rex is it true that originally in that
rain scene you were supposed to run away
from the t-rex but there was a
last-second adjustment to the script
where he distracted the dinosaurs so
that grant could save the kids that's
absolutely right
Steven Spielberg is a genius but and I
hate to take credit and for anything so
I can't really key it was him that
Mulder didn't vote ok did but I did have
an idea I thought my character it was
written in the script that my character
did exactly kind of what the lawyer did
and I was another scared person who just
ragged didn't know what they were doing
but ran away from this scene and then
the t-rex chased after me and and poked
me and and I had this bad leg which led
me to take my shirt off and suffer for
the rest of the movie and that was it I
said to Steven you know I have an idea
what if my character didn't just get so
scared you were but was kind of heroic
and brave and said it's going to result
in the same blocking in the same idea
but said I'm gonna distract this thing
it's Alan Grant Sam Neill you take get
the
kids and protect them come on and I like
the flare I don't think I wasn't
supposed to light the flare come on
dinosaur chase me chase me and get away
from kids he said let me think about
that I don't know I was on call it
wasn't the last second but in that day
it was all on that day and he finally
said let me see you do that how that
would that go Shane they know I showed
okay to do that try that that's how it
went
16:10 heap anyway I know I look very
dainty when I when I do this you know
that's okay I don't care that's terrible
oh that's horrible where's my gut bucket
oh I know the spit bucket the spit
bucket is one you know for heaven's
sakes how dare you oh that's terrible
[Music]
pretty good I like it I like it
it's the provocative yet hmm yet
accessible goodbye yeah yeah oh good
yeah the milk oat milk is the antidote
to spicy that's what you're meant to do
if you really have a spicy you know
that's why it's I'm here okay all right
okay mmmmmm so you've said that one of
the great foundational lessons that
you've learned from legendary acting
coach sandy Meisner is that you're only
interesting to the extent which are
interested you're only interesting to
the extent that you're interested yes
yes you said something like that that's
right how has that advice helped you
outside of your acting career it's a
very very good question
well you know the danger in acting is
that you go oh boy I'm being witnessed I
need to create some effect I need to do
something about myself and so your
attention kind of can easily get trapped
this away and that that's that's not so
good
but yes in life too I think it's healthy
in the short time as we've said we have
so foolish it would be to not if every
day ingest and attend to what the heck
is going on and all the things that
you're probably never gonna get to but
why not continue to be engaged and
interested in in in our life and in our
world in our universe don't you think so
I believe so yeah I do too I do too
[Laughter]
[Music]
de bomb beyond insanity it says hang on
hang on you got a Jeff oh oh that's
terrible
it just I had it my mind I thought
nothing nothing then it then it hit it
hit down I'm not trying to over
dramatize this but that was so that was
alarming so I'm gonna take a wing to
focus on fashion okay I know that you've
described yourself as a fancy lad and
according to Esquire the new elder
statesman of style so what I want to do
is hit you with some fashion trends that
are bubbling up in 2018 and I'm just
curious about the Jeff Goldblum take
does that sound good
okay all right first things first who
wore this Pradas shirt better you or
push a T that's investor Smith yeah he's
got an under under thing they're going
on a little bit of a layer situation
it's fantastic how much III give the
prize to him hands hands down what are
your thoughts on Kanye West Desert Storm
Easy's I really don't know these days
you see so many my eyes are over full
with with the designs things my place
fine and dandy
I like that off-white thing I know I'm
talking too much about it but fine and
dandy ah there you go you like off-white
how about these these Balenciaga trip
glasses
I think you do I have this sure so this
is the one issue that it's the dad
comfortable shoe but it's crazy my wife
Emily
when I first brought home those gray
shoes
she says why what are those and she
laughed at me and then she infected my
our son with that same idea I was the
butt of the joke for a while and I'd
come into the room with those shoes and
then Charlie would laugh he'd go big
shoes big shoes and they'd both be
laughing at me big shoes but then
something happened she became aware or
something we were ahead of the curve she
showed up with a pair in her closet the
other day they're colorful they're not
the gray there's some color they're not
discolored bred they're like that and
she loves them and I love to see her in
them she's so sexy in them she's got the
machines oh she's a gymnast she was a
she's and she still possesses the most
beautiful body I've ever seen in my life
and her legs are perfect sculptures and
she puts on a little soxhlet the laser
and she puts on that shoe with a dress
and we've been together seven years but
I'm still
fascinated fascinate deeply fascinated
by her
so this next one is the Hellfire fiery
fool ah god I don't like it already make
it stop I don't like the pieces of
orange I don't like it the way it looks
I'm scared
I like that Charlie goes I'm scared I'm
scared he admits freely when he's
frightened I find it so hard breaking
her anyway I'm very frightened I know
it's good at this point but as soon as I
mix a little saliva with it and start
started journey I just got to chills you
saw so Jeff the fly came out in 1986 and
I know that it's lasting cultural impact
includes getting name checked and
hip-hop lyrics from everyone from
childish gambino to Kendrick Lamar did
you know that Jeff know I've known that
it's been referenced here there somebody
sent me this that I didn't know childish
gambino or Kenner tomorrow no I don't
think I did the reference is always
something like flyer than Jeff Goldblum
or something to that effect which i
think is a nice pun but it's also a
little tip to your drip Jeff what's that
mean for heaven's sakes you hear swag
your swag if you just drip it like look
at you right now you're dripping no
dripping with style a tip to my drip oh
I'm gonna pepper that I'm gonna use that
ah well good good good lovely I'm very
flattered honored and humbled so this
one is off of Childish Gambino's
sweatpants year off got no rules
tripping off them toadstools more green
than my Whole Foods and I'm too fly Jeff
Goldblum I like it Once Upon a midnight
dreary while I pondered weak and weary
quoth the raven nevermore
let me give you this bar from Kendrick
Lamar okay and now I'll give you another
bit of my poetry draped in some fly [ __ ]
call me Jeff Goldblum cold my style
making my nose run high I'll give you a
bit of poetry back mm-hmm
[Music]
elbow room cried Daniel Boone lovely
just the last stanza of that poem it's
called elbow room I think but I've made
it to say it rhymes better elbow room
cried Jeff Goldblum whoa no I can make
my own I don't need anybody else to make
a Jeff Goldblum what are we doing we
were shaking something up I know
[Music]
hi Jeff this is the last tab we call it
the last tab because it's tradition
around here to put a little extra on the
last with what we don't have to if you
don't want to I have to
after I'm as you know I'm deeply
competitive and virile barrel to last
drop what-what-what-what product used to
be is that oh that's the one that's for
shaking upon it okay
so I don't need to then I want okay all
this but this already has it in it
it already has it and I'm sure there's
plenty believe you'll be okay this is
the last one last dad read I I'm not
gonna be part of the Wall of shame I've
already as soon as I take this bike I'm
not gonna cross the finish line made the
Adria and yo Adrian I did it oh yeah I
took more than I'd want to do but okay
here we go we go here we go
[Music]
nothing nothing
something
okay we are at the end of the line and
as hot ones fans know it's out with the
old and in with the new every season so
some of these hot sauces are going to be
retired before we send them off to
pasture I think we give them the tribute
that they deserve okay I'd love for you
to go down the line and rate each one of
these hot sauces on a scale from zero to
ten Goldblum's
ish ish taken Season six out in style
let's start with the howler monkey
howler monkey I give that shake well I
like shake well I give that ten out of
ten buildings that's as high as you can
go very very good I don't know what
we're gonna retire oh I like this really
I like the way that comes out I like the
whole thing ontario canadian ten go
bulls pirates mentor I am The Pirate
King and it is it is a glorious thing to
be a Pirate King The Pirate King 10
doldrums out of a possible 10 golems
isolate that are chrome Comics 10 gold
runs out of a possible 10 golems the
scallion yes I love all peoples of the
world we're all after all living on a
little planet 10 golems out of a
possible 10 dolphins I like that title
black garlic it sounds sexy to me 10
golems that of a possible 10 governors
if you were John Huston
I was Humphrey Bogart you know we would
knock back a couple of things be manly
men
10:07 prostitute opens oh yeah bomb of
course I don't know why duh has an
apostrophe after it it's is something
being left out of their like to chock
full o'Nuts this is a scary clown of
course with the Harlequin print
I've always wanted a Harlequin print
I've always wanted to be a Harlequin
printed something 10 gold looks out of a
possible ten goblins well this is the
last the last dad redux this is your
good look this is your good thing first
we feast I wouldn't have known that had
I not paid attention to some of the fine
print well this of course gets 11
Goldblum's
the only time I've ever given that
congratulations of a possible 10 golems
11 gold blooms well if Jeff says it then
it's gospel then it's the truth and look
at you Jeff Goldblum all the way through
the vegan chicken wing gauntlet closing
out season six in style listen to my
vocal chords they sound I'm as
mellifluous and full-throated as I've
ever been
maybe even more full-throated now yes
and stayed off the Wall of shame I know
you had a little bit of a fear I did and
now there's nothing left to do but roll
out the red carpet for you my friend
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life thank you thank you not
that I need to do this I'm not nothing
I'm I'm nose kind of salesman but I am I
going to the Venice Film Festival like
we said to premiere this movie the
mountain of which I'm very proud it is a
special item for those who may be
interested in such a thing it is it is
very special I have I love it likewise
this albus record with the mildred
schnitzer orchestra it's coming out I'm
ecstatic over it I love it I feel bonded
to you forever this has been fantastic
thank you Jeff great to meet you we're
friends for life thank you
congratulations on season six
good job dub good job thank you baby
come on that was fun wasn't that fine Oh
baby come on my life
you got something useful there here
there we're we're a good team
but this is us okay cuz it's us look at
you
so speaking of no socks I was gonna say
well someone look at their hairy ankles
I know I went who has hairy ankles that
hairy but I knew you have hairy ankles
but I wouldn't say lose them keep that
hair you think Harry and the Hendersons
yeah this is a nice shirt Jeff would you
like it I do I like it a lot you remind
me of my friend that actor the son of
James Caan Scott Caan you know Scott
Caan no but I'm gonna look him up after
this oh yeah
Scott Caan ISA he's been on Hawaii
five-o five-o all this time he's the son
of James Caan James Caan of course is
starred most famously in what movie no
no deaf James Caan was one of the
Corleone family and of course the
Godfather's which you've seen maybe not
or maybe you have many times and he
played which which child Michael
Corleone was of course Al Pacino
Fredo is John Cazale Talia Shire was
Connie and of course James Caan was was
he was known for the family of his hot
temper speaking of hot ones and his
large penis he had a larger penis I mean
the movie in the book and I'm in the
movie a million to 1 million three
that's pretty good form Phil then you
get that cool shirt you didn't hear how
ones merch it's available now I thought
you only wore Where's Waldo shirts I
used to wear where all their shirts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one
[Music]